we try to get things right on the show
but when we make a mistake we correct it
immediately and we're doing that now for
several years we have told you that eric
swalwell was the single
dumbest member of congress the absolute
dimmest of the 535 herd animals who make
your laws we meant it when we said it
but things change the facts on the
ground
they're different corey bush was elected
to office and swallow lost his throne
it's sad but swalwell still serves with
distinction he's the only elected
official in washington we can say with
confidence
has had sex with a chinese spy that's
not nothing
we've got time to think from time to
time he's probably sitting in the house
steam room bragging about it swole is
that kind of guy
of course hall is no longer having sex
with that particular spy
she's fled the country ahead of federal
investigators so there's a hole in
suawell's life
where a sexy spy once was hence the new
job posting
the swallow's office has just announced
they're looking for someone
to quote find creative ways to expand
the congressman's
brand apparently that's the euphemism
they're going with hey baby
expand to my brand solo claims he's
progressive
but he's got some pretty old-fashioned
requirements for the brand expander
he wants this person to be a woman not a
dude not a trans person but a verified
chick
preferably someone with a quote diverse
background and
lived experiences what kind of lived
experiences is eric swellow talking
about well it's a family show so we're
not going to speculate on that but you
can imagine what he's talking about
meow hot times with congressman spy
sex so alert your daughters this is not
a job they want
beijing send your best
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else